[Applause]
that is true something in my eye whole
world's falling apart happy Monday
everybody so like anyone who ever bought
a book by Brian
kilme we understand buyer's
remorse and these days nobody gets that
better than your average Democrat as Joe
Biden continues his worldwide confusion
tour more and more voters have taken to
steaming that dump Trump sticker off
their pre is in a brand new poll Donald
Trump now leads Joe Biden in five of six
swing states that Trump lost in
2020 look at
that I haven't seen so many people
regreted decision since CNN gave n
billion bucks to Chris
Wallace apparently many Dems have
started to notice what none of us were
supposed to that things were far better
and safer under Donald Trump than Joe
Biden you remember those days when your
car wasn't stolen and your son wasn't
pregnant true like watching The View
talk about their weight
loss the disparity between what you're
told is true and the evidence of our own
eyes has become impossible to
ignore and now even liberal thought
leaders are starting to sound about as
coherent as the voices in comm's head
after 3 hours of vaping window
cleaner recently on the podcast
trigonometry philosopher Sam Harris
who's an expert at being simultaneously
wrong and sanctimonious had this to say
about Trump I mean you think of all the
things we didn't get done and will not
get done for every moment we spend
dealing with the divisiveness of
trumpism and and the counter reaction
from the left I mean it's just it's just
a massive opportunity cost so no I think
it's there's nothing good e even if you
can find some local instance where Trump
was right about something uh and the
Democrats were wrong I mean he's he's
totally right about the southern
border so like opening that Igloo cooler
with your Tinder dat's head in it let's
unpack
that Harris says that Israel got
attacked because America took its Eye
Off the Ball Trump was so awful a person
that half the country just couldn't
entertain his ideas it's the
intellectual equivalent of putting your
hands over your ears and making siren
noises now of course this ignores the
fact that there was another half of the
country that didn't have its hands over
its ears and could hear president Trump
but we know that half doesn't exist for
guys like Harris they're just the people
who drive his Uber and bring his coffee
order you know like Jimmy fail it does
for
me and it also shows how insane Trump
derangement syndrome was what Harris is
saying is that yes the world was safer
under Trump but I'd rather have World
War I than Mean Tweets at least that
gets rid of my personal angst Harris
then admits that one of the left's
favorite unsupported charges against
Trump his supposed racism was used to
discredit even the ideas that they
agreed with there's absolutely no
defense of having an indefensible border
we should know who's coming into the
country build the wall I mean yes if the
wall is the best way to to secure that
border then Build That Wall right so
Trump's right about that but he's such
an awful human being and his effect on
our politics is so toxic that we can't
even that that that half of our society
has to treat that completely San project
as a form of racism because they're
reacting to the the the Golem of of
trump now only an intellectual could
sound so dumb we need a wall and we know
it but let's call Trump a racist to make
sure we don't get it he's saying he was
wrong because he's biased but that's
good congratulations you got tenure
meanwhile the rest of us knew Trump
wasn't racist I mean how could could
someone who hates people of color spend
40 Grand a year on bronzing
cream when you when you listen to Harris
it's like asking the cop who he voted
for before he pulls you from that
burning car here's the point even after
voting Trump out of office Liberals are
still obsessed with him the Panic never
stopped if I were a therapist I would
treat Democrats this way please show me
on this doll where Trump hurt you
they would all point to their
heads talk about missed opportunity
costs the Biden Administration the
Legacy Media and even our great
philosophers just can't quit you Donald
so it's not Trump at all it's their
psyche which means to me if you like
Trump's policies but hated the constant
presence of trump you should still vote
Trump anyway because whether he wins or
not the obsession will still always be
there so you have a choice Trump
Obsession and Biden politics or Trump
Obsession and Trump
policies see like Joe Biden it's a
[Laughter]
no-brainer fact is it's Biden who
continues to take his squinty eyes off
the ball too bad that ball doesn't have
blonde hair and the fragrance of baby
shampoo that would keep his attention
but do you think the Hamas attack would
have happened if we weren't focusing on
Ukraine's border 247 if we weren't
consumed by the White House Embrace of
identity politics if we weren't fearful
over rampid crime in our cities if we
had to worry about being canceled or
Worse being jailed over beliefs instead
we got all of that plus Trum Trump
derangement but without the Trump policy
so we get the whining and paranoia
without the Hardline on Islamic
radicalism the relationship with Israel
and the Iron Fist on
immigration look if we're going to have
to hear all this belly aching can we at
least feel safe while doing it now it's
nice that Sam Harris was willing to say
the left's quiet part out loud but that
doesn't change the fact that what he
admits the Dems have been doing is
entirely dishonest and has made this
country much less safe nobody's afraid
of us anymore our president has become a
punch line and our country a punching
bag if the world was jaded pinket we'd
be
Smith but voters are waking up as Wars
break out everywhere they're suddenly
missing the president whose terribly
mean demeanor actually kept the world in
line but there's another strange thing
happening even when Trump's out of power
the fear of him ascending is already
changing Behavior Dems realized they
can't fight two Wars they can't let
violent felons roam free they can't let
our border collapse it seems the only
thing that gets Dems to act like adults
is the fear that they will lose to that
childish Trump in a way they're like a
guy who traded in his big muscle car for
a little electric Mini Cooper but
suddenly the guy's missing all that
muscle all that power the Roar of that
V8 engine sure it was noisy and
sometimes it was annoying and yeah it
was
orange but you know what every other car
on the road gets the hell out of its way
and now it's time maybe Biden do the
same let's welcome nice guest she's
never been asked to pick up the pace
host of the fox true cry podcast Emily
compo he's the only doctor I call for
prostate exams host of ask Dr Drew Dr
Drew
Pinsky Palestinians and Israelis have
agreed on one thing they hate his jokes
writer and comedian Joe
deito and finally her wit so dry it
causes brush fires New York Times
bestselling author and Fox new
contributor cat
[Music]
tuo you know Emily there's this belief
that when you get Trump you get Trump
derangement syndrome but if you just
replace him with any Republican it's
going to be insert that name derangement
syndrome whether it's the santis or
whoever it's going to be the same thing
do you agree say yes and we'll move on
yes yes and yes and uh for sure that
hatred is transferable but he holds that
unique position where he will always be
the Pinnacle to the left um you said in
the beginning in the intro how in those
six five of the six swing states he is
absolutely demolishing Biden in the
polls and I just think it Bears worth
underscoring that um he's leading in the
economy by 22 points in those States and
others Americans absolutely trust him
more than anything with their most
precious commodity right now which is
providing for their family
and yet think about what else the New
York Times uncovered today they said
they found out because of a poll that in
those six swing states that 6% of Voters
if he was convicted would switch their
votes to Biden and that 6% is enough to
potentially sway the election and they
were crowing about it their headline
read Trump indictments haven't sunk his
campaign but a conviction M and when you
put that against the landscape of
Leticia James crowing during her
campaign about he's a con man and she's
going to get him you know this is
someone who employs over 30,000 people
this is someone who has been paying
taxes and providing for this city and
this state and so many Arenas and yet
all they want to do is kill the Beast
they are hinging their hat on any
conviction come hell high water because
now they know as one voter said I can't
elect a criminal leader so they're going
to do whatever they can and whatever it
takes to make sure he has that tag next
to his name because apparently
preserving and protecting America isn't
enough and quick final point because Sam
Harris to bring up the Golem that's a
Jewish sort of mythological monster and
the audacity to bring that up now as
Hamas and Islamic Jihad and so many have
pledged the erad eradication of Jewish
people in their culture under this
administration's watch and because of
this administration's leniency and and
Iran enablement to me is so rich the
left needs to get it together but take
it as a warning I'm afraid they really
are going to do everything they can to
convict him and that wasn't a quick
point it is true though that b in some
issues Biden is down to single digits do
you know what that single digit
is uh anyway uhoh sorry
editors uh Dr Drew okay I mean it's been
going on for three years since he left
office and it just gets worse yeah
should the D is it called the DMS dsm5
dsm5 have Trump derangement as a medical
disorder well we're getting close I
think and it's certainly hysteria right
I mean the hysteria there ain't no
derangement like Trump derangement you
know you're talking about it being
transferable I don't think anyone can
create it the way he does and I feel as
though the hysteria around Co the
hysteria around many things the border
the kids and cages all this hysteria is
in fact diagnosable but we've been swept
up by it in some very strange way the
other thing I I'm a Sam Harris fan I've
been for years but there're so
interesting watching his cognitive
distance take hold it's almost like
steam's coming out of his ears and he
say very specific he says you know
Southern border he was correct I just
don't like him I thought wow I don't
like him is not a way to judge a
presidential candidate Abraham Lincoln
was not liked no during his lifetime he
he was an he was not liked by almost
anyone because they used to talk joeo no
Biden oh Biden get with the program
sorry sorry gotta keep up with you but
it's just so interesting me that we're
using like like high school or Junior
High School I don't like him as our
criteria yeah it's the same criteria Joe
that you would have for like your lawyer
or your agent you want to have somebody
who defends you the best way it doesn't
matter if they're an a-hole yeah exactly
what's the point of having a a a a weak
good tempered schmuck you can't get the
job done I think what drives them nuts
the most is that no matter what they
throw at Trump it's incredible he looks
better now than he did when he became
president yeah that never happens with
presidents they all come out looking
like mummies yeah and I think it's so
funny the way he breaks people's brains
to me the best was Elizabeth Warren how
he kept pushing her and pushing her and
she came out with a DNA test that said
she was one 1,000 and she was like you
see you see it was all for Donald and
and and then when they said what do you
think he said who
cares so he got her good um yeah I think
if if um Trump is amazing and I'm I'm
watching him in the courtroom and
whatever they're throwing at him first
of all the sketch artist made him look
like Edward monks the scream where he's
like he's like this but then you see in
Trump's world you look at his lawyer and
it's like of course he has a smoking hot
lawyer that's the way Trump rolls yeah
so if if if they're if they send them to
jail I think we need to switch the way
we we elect presidents I think we need
to do something like jury duty where you
get something in the mail and you're
just a random person's like H do this
for four years yeah exactly it's not
worth it anymore Cat hello how are you
I'm great excellent you look like one of
the world's most successful real estate
agents
I
am C what do you think about this first
of all excellent
question that's why you're sitting over
there uh yeah I mean I honestly it's
kind of surprising to see him say it um
I'm just overwhelmed honestly with a
sense of dread yeah just like we're
going to have to do all this again it's
going to be exactly the same it's going
to be everybody's going to say this the
history of the country hinges on this
election which I don't know man now that
we see that we have a president that
doesn't really know what's going onh and
I wouldn't say things are great things
are pretty bad but we're still a country
so I don't think you can say that
anymore yeah it's going to be a lot of
the same stuff and it's the two same
people and I think that it's really rare
to see somebody actually be honest about
listen I just don't like the guy it's
usually a lot more moral emotional
language gets involved but then a lot of
people actually do believe it yeah and
they get genuinely upset and then we
make decisions based on that and I don't
know I mean I'm not going to vote for
either one of them so did you see Rob
riner's tweet today where he said that
the Democracy hinges on no third party
really you can't have democracy with
third party and Trump being convicted
yeah there you go they can't win they
can't win fairly so they got to throw
the guy in jail I think if if Trump's
opinions were the exact opposite those
people would have gone the exact
absolutely if he had said wear masks and
come on in Mexico the view in Rob Riner
would be RI masks off people's faces and
stacking them up at the for the vaccine
we're in California we weren't going to
touch that vaccine that is Trump's
vaccine then all of a sudden everyone
has to have the vaccine all right hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else